nous
gagné près de 10000 euros par seconde
vous intéresse bonjour mon nom et
stéphane je vais vous montrer une
technique pour gagner près de 10000
euros par seconde sans bouger de chez
vous sans même sortir de votre lit sans
même vous réveiller sans même en avoir
conscience
cette technique est basée sur une
méthode qu'utilise les traders américain
aussi appelée american thriller
certains peuvent penser que cela est
fastidieux et complexe pourtant c'est
très simple regardez la méthode
consistant à parier en fait sur des
courbes eux
bon je sais plus exactement mais
pourtant c'est très simple la preuve
certaines personnes ont véritablement
adopté cette technique et en sont
aujourd'hui très heureux
grâce à cette méthode
j'ai pu gagner plus de 10000 euros par
minute grosse par seconde sans sortir de
chez moi c'est bon stéphane je suis
allée jean non non c'est bon j'ai joué
maintenant tu as ça marche
véritablement vous n'êtes pas convaincu
laissez moi vous le prouver avec mon
propre argent je mise par exemple 5
euros sur une valeur de bourse montante
au postulat aléatoire alors maintenant 5
euros
alors ça dépend peut-être que c'est pas
le bon jour
bon ça marche souvent en tout cas cette
technique fonctionne en quatre étapes
vraiment très simple easy et heeb
connectez vous à notre site internet
énorme arnaque tirer on se fout
littéralement de votre gueule point
argent entrer vos coordonnées bancaires
ensuite c'est tout voilà attendait
faites vous un café mettez vos l'aise
vous pouvez vaquer à d'autres
occupations
l'argent va va va se faire cette méthode
est garanti à 100 roubles mhl le risug
la sq et genève faites moi confiance
cette méthode marche à 100 % plus elle
est vraiment garantit le computer à rome
des centaines de personnes l'ont déjà
adoptée en sont très heureux on prend
quand on en aura pas cergy oui faites
moi confiance
non non et stéphane lecat meros clavier
il révèle plus tard vous voulez vraiment
gagner de l'argent je vais vous donner
une technique infaillible jeune âge il
vous suffit d'aller au pôle emploi et de
travailler ça c'est une technique qui
marche bien ça l'arbre faites moi
confiance je m'appelle stéphane abonnez
vous à ma chaîne youtube